North Korea Kim Jung on he is well he
wants to launch a preemptive nuclear
strike on America he's not happy with us
because of some military stuff going on
over there they just ripped up the truce
with South Korea which I guess means the
North Korean South Korean War is back on
so you know I guess the Korean vets are
gonna be in some trouble uh what do we
think about this because it seems crazy
like everyone was sort of laughing I was
watching mainstream news a row yeah
North Korea is gonna nuke us you know
and everyone's laughing about it but
should we take this kind of stuff
seriously Kim jong-un announcing that
we're gonna be at nuclear war or he's
gonna have a nuclear war against the
United States is like cher announcing
she's gonna retire it's never you know
what I mean like we're never gonna get
to that point so I am fascinated by this
man I'm fascinated by this country and I
think there I totally am in favor of the
sanctions being put again I also think
it's really interesting that China's
going along with these UN sanctions
which is telling in terms of their
closer to where the nuclear material is
well yeah but even then I mean it
doesn't it I think China is even
learning as probably because of money
but they're learning that it doesn't
benefit them to keep supporting this
country that they're trying to kill out
this country and the country's letting
themselves die I think I mean Kim
jong-un is killing its people and China
is now realizing we need to abandon ship
on you guys I mean what do you make of
this kind of like over-the-top rhetoric
there obviously first off it they don't
have missiles that they can attach this
stuff too so everyone saying at best
they could create some sort of you know
dirty bomb situation but what do you
think of just the rhetoric and the level
of you know saber rattling typically you
know it's discussed as well you know
they're just trying to get more
attention you know cuz when they do
these huge threats that you know that's
saber rattling like you said that they
actually then get the United States
against it down and okay give us some
more a give them some more money help
them to you just basically get the
attention that they want and now that
you know Kim jong-un i think is it is it
this i was working i'm straight that
he's actually trying to cement his
position in the
media at home and abroad as well I think
it's really interesting that china is
getting involved in this it's it's it's
it's really it's like a psychological
thriller in a way because you get to
find out this crazy guy and why is he
doing this because he knows he can be
wiped off the map so and ironically and
I think this is what you were alluding
to China can't have us get nuked because
then they wouldn't be able to call in
the debt so I have a feeling that you
think that this has something to do with
Dennis Rodman am i right I you know I
heard that after hanging out with Rob
and they're gonna be both on Celebrity
Rehab next year but uh I was gonna say
who would have thought that it at a
Korean guys missile couldn't reach his
destination because huh they have small
penis how bad it is okay haha it said
the twitter feed I don't have a hundred
hunter the comic Adam comedian adam
comedian but i was a big fan of this
guy's music with Gangnam style yeah I
don't know why didn't tell him that our
presidents hanging out with jay-z and
he's hanging out with Dennis Rodman like
you know Apple we're definitely winning
in the situation every front gave him
Dennis Rodman what more does he want
what more can I wanted to stay well you
know what's funny i was watching a
celebrity apprentice a couple nights ago
and Dennis Rodman is now on Celebrity
Apprentice and despite the lunatics that
he's on that show it like Gary Busey and
the rest of these overly plastic surgery
people he still comes off as the
craziest one and that's the guy that we
sent with the Globetrotters if you
laterz having like ron artest as a
normal one right peace is another one
that's how bad Kobe and Dwight Howard
are what are you guys making that that
we send these people I mean we literally
sent Dennis Rodman and the Globetrotters
to North Korea to somehow those Asian
other states part I was very clear that
they did not have anything to do with
this then yeah the State Department how
does one you get to north 33 on HBO yeah
and like the Carlin Globetrotters we're
going to the Philippines and doing this
whole thing they were following them
around or something like that and ended
up in Korea I'm not sure exact but I
know that it was part of an HBO the show
it was money well I guess the point here
is that we're talking about nukes and
yeah Dennis Rodman in the same story and
that's bizarre I think that North Korea
and South Korea should have a big game
of Dance Dance Revolution I think
if you go to the arcade it's all Asian
people they're just dancing on that and
I think that that dance diplomacy with
us I would love to see Hillary Clinton
do that thank you so much fun I knew you
were gonna get a health I had to be like
four top of my going on this war tops
ago everyone if a terrorist others on US
soil at the drones I don't mind and not
US citizens droning attacks just to get
bigger if it was it was a foreign
terrorist hanging out at like Applebee's
I wouldn't mind a drone just [ __ ]
like that depends on what the definition
of combat it precisely that's why it's
who do you leave all this stuff up to
that's where the real discussion about
all this is bonobos calm is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report get this
shirt use code trr 20 effin elbows com